and i'm back on the streak believe it or  not  and i'm playing the hammer  the best way to get off a streak  and c9 is not on the street so if you  win now not a five is a threat that's a  good  okay we'll take it  is there are there no tactics here okay  i guess we'll just take them  that f5 after h5  all right nazi too  so blind  oh  i thought he'd e5 on knight f3  didn't work because g5 was hanging  but it's fine  it's sad man it's fine  i didn't go for a [ __ ] before  with the fork  unfortunately  i'm doing okay though  it's not a good game  let's  try and make him this bishop a little  bit short of air  can you afford this  takes queen of fate  but i guess i don't have anything there  i'm not going to even draw obviously  even though my position is worse  we try to make the trick maybe we mix  the trick now  looks like this could be made now  let's mate oh  rook d5  oh rook d5 rookie one  king h2 knight f3  and then rook g1 that's why he resigned  because he saw that